what up guys welcome to the just Hurley
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a video that one of my
subscribers sent me before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos this video
um apparently is from like the mgtow
group which is men going their own way
so it's to like explain that a little
bit more um he felt like I had some
misconceptions that like some stuff I
maybe got wrong so I'm is here to
educate and learn so I'm excited to see
this also DM me on Instagram just pearly
things one if you guys have any you know
videos that you think would be good for
me to react to Welcome to the dojo the
series where I'll teach you the mgtow
skills necessary to identify and protect
yourself from gynocentric and feminist
threats while I already had plans to
discuss this issue a patreon member
provided me the motivation to address
this subject sooner rather than later
with that in mind it's time for your
first lesson many people believe that
the reason married men get taken
advantage of by women is because they
quote unquote chose the wrong woman I
hear this all the time it's always like
what type of women are you talking to
like not all women are like that like
that's always the first response however
a fair number of blue pilled men also
blame and shame these men for allowing
themselves to be divorce rape or
otherwise victimized yeah Hafiz did that
during the interview I did with him some
even go so far as to say that the
targeted man had it coming as more and
more men take the red pill and start
perceiving in a woman's hypergamy and
female nature for what they truly are
they're starting to avoid marriage on
September 14 2017 the Pew Research
Center published a report entitled as
U.S marriage rates hover at 50 percent
education Gap in marital status widens
while this article is focused on
marriage as it relates to education they
disclose a very important fact half of
U.S adults today are married a share
that has remained relatively stable in
recent years but is down nine percentage
points over the last quarter century and
dramatically different from the peak of
72 percent in 1960 according to new
release census data in 1960 before the
rise of feminism 72 percent are almost
three quarters of American adults were
married today that number has dropped to
50 percent this represents a 33 percent
decrease in marriage thanks to
feminism's war on marriage a month later
in October 2017 the Pew Research Center
published the report the share of
Americans living without a partner has
increased especially among adults in it
they State the share of young adults who
are unpartnered has increased Across The
Young and the middle age but the rise
has been most pronounced among young
adults roughly 6 in 10 adults younger
than 35 years old 61 percent are now
Living Without A Partners oh wow so 61
are living without a spouse or partner
under 35 well I didn't realize it was
that high I knew like the marital rates
like that I'd heard but I hadn't heard
um as much about living alone thus since
second wave feminism's war on marriage
began in the 1960s one of the long-term
consequences is it not only has the
marriage rate dropped by 33 percent but
6 in 10 unmarried adults under 35 are
refusing to live with their girlfriends
and boyfriends this is one of the
reasons that I always say that feminism
destroyed the social contract between
men and women with that in mind lots of
men especially puas Trad cons and other
red pill Bros think that avoiding
marriage by itself is a solution to
avoid having their assets stolen repute
station destroyed and otherwise be
divorce rate once feminism realized that
men were starting to protect themselves
from divorce rape by avoiding marriage
they worked to change the laws around
the world to persecute single men as
well today in Australia a man doesn't
have to be married to get divorce rate
the family court of Australia stated on
May 3rd 2016 a de facto relationship is
defined in section 4aa of the Family Law
act of 1975 the law requires that you
and your former partner who may be of
the same or opposite sex had a
relationship as a couple living together
on a genuine domestic basis wow so even
if a guy doesn't want to get married you
hear that blessing even if a guy doesn't
want to get married if he lives with the
girl she she can still pursue him in
court that's crazy that's crazy further
ABC News Australia interviewed Rachel
sharer the founder of divorceanswer.com
in June 2017 and she said there's no
timeline and there's no minimum time
period as long as you and your partner
considered yourself in a considered or
committed relationship what two could
live with a girl for two months three
months as long as other people recognize
that then you're in a de facto
relationship even more frightening she
stated there's a relationship called de
facto by distance which means that even
though you may not be living together
exclusively and full time as long as you
stay in each other's house or home when
you're in each other's local space then
you're definitely considered in a de
facto relationship thus in Australia
even if she doesn't live with you full
time and she just stays the night or she
just leaves her [__] in your home she
can divorce rape you
blessing
yeah so she leaves her [__] in your
apartment she can divorce you that's
crazy
with paper wait so she can take off
we're gonna find out we're gonna yeah
let's see United States multiple states
have adopted common law marriage laws in
a very basic sense their laws that state
that if you and your girlfriend live
together for a certain period of time
then you're considered married and can
be divorce raped according to the
National Conference of State
legislatures the states that still have
common law marriage are Colorado Iowa
Kansas Montana New Hampshire South
Carolina and Utah while Washington State
doesn't have common law marriage laws
they do recognize maritricious
relationships divorcenet a website
published by Nolo describes these
relationships as follows the term
meritricious has been historically used
to label the cohabitation of unmarried
couples when a cohabitation ends the
couple will usually face the same issues
that arise in the divorce the most
common include the following division of
assets and property paying debts and
determining child custody and child
support thus not only can an unmarried
man get divorce raped in states that
recognize common law marriages but in
Washington state they can get divorce
raped under their meritritious
relationship laws it's a good thing
we're moving to Tennessee or Florida
thank God however even worse than these
feminist laws created to divorce rape
unmarried men are the feminist-sponsored
domestic violence laws in 1980 the
feminists created the Duluth model of
domestic violence intervention today
it's the most commonly used domestic
violence program in the world in the
United States over 30 States mandate its
use however even in places that don't
use it they still pattern their DV laws
on it why is this important it's because
the Duluth model created the world's
first civil domestic violence
restraining order thus a woman can
accuse you of rape domestic violence or
sexual abuse in a civil court without
your knowledge and obtain an order to
divorce rape you wait so wait I need to
incorporate I need to understand what
they said so she can accuse you of
assault or domestic violence without you
knowing yeah sounds like it okay this is
true even in states that don't recognize
common law marriage also I've heard of
these types of civil court orders being
entered in the UK Canada Australia and
other Western countries that have
adopted feminist policies let me break
it down further like I think basically
it means you don't like she can oh wait
I think I understand so she can go to
go and basically
and not actually take you to court for
the abuse and so she can divorce you or
like divorce grape you on the grounds of
abuse without you actually being found
guilty of abuse yeah yeah I think okay
what follows are snapshots taken of
Washington State's civil domestic
violence restraining order request
pattern forms while other state and
international jurisdictions forms May
differ they're all patterned after
Duluth model format and were created to
divorce rape unmarried men in the first
picture a woman can tell the court that
you live together and request the court
have the police evict you from your home
without notice giving her sole
possession and leaving you homeless
further she what wait so basically I
think I think I'm understanding so she
can go to the court say that you abused
her and then kick you out of your house
without any proof that like actually
going to court for the abuse requests
the court have the police help her steal
your separate property and your car thus
she can lawfully steal anything of value
you own also she can request the court
order you into counseling Mental Health
Services or drug rehab that's what they
did to Kanye
free Kanye
addition to holding you responsible for
any fees and costs associated with her
attempt to divorce rape you even worse
she can request the court to order you
to surrender your lawfully owned
firearms and bar you from your Second
Amendment right to own a firearm as well
as revoke your lawfully obtained
concealed carry permit so how common are
civil domestic violence restraining
orders granted in the United States well
in 2011
safeservices.org issued a 12-page
special report entitled The use and
abuse of domestic violence restraining
orders in it they State on page seven
one analysis compiled data on Final
restraining orders mostly in 2002 from
29 state court systems and found that
the rates varied widely across the
states on average the analysis revealed
that 342 final restraining orders were
issued per 100 000 persons when
extrapolated to the entire U.S
population an estimated of eight hundred
and sixty thousand final orders were
granted now remember this is per year
that calculation parallels data from the
FBI National Crime information center
ncic which includes a National Registry
of restraining orders each year six
hundred thousand to seven hundred
thousand permanent orders are entered
into the registry however eight states
do not participate in the ncic registry
and many other states have incomplete
coverage for example in Texas 25
counties do not report in California 17
counties do not have a reliable
procedure to enter orders into their
database given the trend of increasing
numbers of restraining order the best
estimate of final restraining orders now
issued each year is nine hundred
thousand that's right as of 2011 almost
a million civil DV restrain orders are
granted each year in the U.S alone and
civil DV restraining orders I don't from
what if I'm understanding it right don't
actually require them to go to court for
it because they can press Char because
they said they could press charges
without the guy even knowing and how
would you go to court for something so
basically they can accuse him of
something thing he could be like
basically found guilty and have all
these consequences where they can take
his home his his car everything under
the guise that he was abusive and she
could be lying wow and and it could just
be from living with a girl for a couple
of months so she could just leave her
stuff and those only represent the
permanent orders they don't include the
temporary orders like the initial 14. so
there's a million a year that are
temporary orders the orders nor do they
include the orders that actually have
set expiration dates in other words the
one-year restraining orders or the
five-year restraining orders that many
jurisdictions issue prior to issuing the
permit if a girl does it oh my God who
did this and you were not actually a b
hell you deserve to go to hell I swear
to God restraining order the question
that begs to be asked is since the Civil
domestic violence protection order
system was implemented by feminists in
the early 1980s how many millions of men
around the world have had their lives
destroyed through false accusations
without ever being charged with a crime
crazy so let's recap a woman can get a
civil domestic violence protection order
without any notice to you and have you
immediately and forcibly evicted from
your home she can steal your car she can
steal your possessions she can force you
to pay for all the costs associated with
her actions and remember she can do this
in Civil Court without ever needing to
file a police report or have you
criminally charged or convicted for a
crime what worse if you attempt to do
anything to stop her you'll be arrested
and charged for a crime for violating
her protection order if you got evicted
from your home and had your car stolen
as a homeless person without
transportation how long could you keep
your job more importantly how long would
you survive on the streets with that in
mind what's the takeaway it's pretty
simple like I said earlier feminism
destroyed the social contract between
men and women the best way to protect
yourself from being divorce rape as an
unmarried man is to avoid committing
cohabitating or marrying any woman sadly
he even casually dating a woman can get
you divorce rate in any country that
Advocates feminism through the Civil
domestic violence restraining order
system until things change the best
solution remains going mgtow and
avoiding women as much as possible this
concludes today's lesson from the mgtow
dojo and so that's why that oh that
makes a lot of sense because we talk a
lot about abuse and a lot of girls will
claim abuse but a question to ask if I
say did you go to court for it I'll say
was it civil or did you file a police
report because if they go to civil court
we don't even know if that's true
because they didn't even press charges
against him wow that's crazy wow is
there is there any more to this if you
enjoyed this video I just thought wow I
did not know that and and that's the
thing like a lot of times people come at
when they say oh mgtow the men go in
their own way like they're not the men
we want it anyway like I've heard that
many times and I just I feel like when I
go into things like I want to understand
like if it's a large group of people
they probably have a reason um and that
is a pretty damn good reason and that
crazy blessing this
he's like I got to think about this
marriage he's like he's like I'm not
letting anyone leave their stuff take
your stuff home I didn't know that it's
only just leave that stuff and come and
divorce you what
um okay guys let me know what you think
in the comments like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and let
me know if there's more that I should
know um about you know anything red pill
make towel whatever Blackville like the
video subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time